Ladies and gentlemen, it's finally here at long,
last after hours, days, weeks,
months of work on the $10 million studio.
We finally finished on Friday and I am happy to say the
studios up and running better than ever. Welcome to two to one C Baker street,
copy Zillow's office, home of the internet detective.
They said I could be anything. So it became an internet detective.
And I'm going to walk you through my whole set, but I first want to say,
look guys, this is not some amateur operation anymore. We're leveling up.
We are now professional internet detectives.
Does that mean we're better researched or any more knowledgeable than we were
before? No,
but what it does mean is that we have the appearance and the appearance of
credibility,
the appearance of being well-dressed well lit because that's a big lesson I
learned during the pandemic. I got to tell you,
and I hope this inspires you at home. Nobody's smarter than you.
Nobody knows anything. You don't. What they are is they're richer than you.
They're better dressed than you. And they're better left than you.
What's the difference between you and the people immediate. Seriously?
I realized this, actually I was feeling little down and out,
to be honest with you guys, we all experienced those times of self doubt.
I don't know if you guys can relate to that, but who picked me up was not,
you know, it was not my traditional inspirations right now.
I'm going for a cross between somewhere between Chris Cuomo and Alex Jones,
trying to kind of hit all the bases, but that's not who inspired me,
ladies and gentlemen who inspired me were America's sweethearts.
And I'm going to demonstrate it to you actually,
by showing off a little feature of the studio, actually,
these are the people who really made me realize something profound. Yes,
that's right. America's late night hosts. Oh wow.
Were they humbled this year? Weren't they, they had to go back.
They had to get taken away from their beautiful sets from their makeup artists
and torn away from that.
I suddenly felt a lot better about not being that entertaining or funny or
talented. I realized, Hey, these guys aren't either.
It's just movie magic. That's all it is.
Our little brains think that people dressed up in suits lit really
well with beautiful backgrounds. We think they're credible.
There's nothing more or less credible about them.
They've just got a team that dresses them up really nice. So I realized, Oh,
well, if that's the only problem, then we can fix it.
That's something we can fix. I was thinking I had to get a personality,
start writing, funny jokes, but watching these guys,
let me just say I was truly inspired. So I built this. So without further ado,
I want to show you the full set we built.
First thing I want to show you is actually a cool little feature of this screen
back here, where I can show you what's going on. What I'm looking at.
It actually rotates sideways to get, go into like a cool portrait mode.
Check this out.
This is a gigantic or deal setting this up and with that beautiful transition
before I show you anything else, any yet, any of other features of the studio,
I need to introduce you to someone special someone who I could not have done
this about someone who held my hand every step of the way,
someone who supported me through this whole journey.
I'm talking of course of my designer, ed.
And thank you for coming on the show.
You're the architect of a $10 million studio.
I could not have done this without you. Uh,
and the first thing people should know is where you're from.
Because when I was deciding where to hire from,
did I hire from the U S the land of the privileged? No.
So instead I chose Ukraine. Ed,
how are things over there?
Yeah, it's pretty bad.
They're stimulating my economy.
The biggest thing since Hunter Biden, Ukraine,
hasn't had a lot of big ticket Americans come on through.
It's basically Hunter Biden and me stimulating the world economy.
Uh, thank you so much though. You're a legend. When I saw your work,
I haven't seen anything like it. And, um,
I knew you'd be the exact person to take things to the next level.
Just as a curiosity, how was I as a boss?
We've been working on this project together for like how many months now?
It's like a couple of months, I think like, uh, in my,
in my schedule it was, but it feels like years. Really.
Okay. That's how we're going to do this interview. Okay. All right. Listen,
in all seriousness,
you have your own YouTube channel starting up called be memorable.
Go check him out guys. He's on the come up.
You crane is a rising world power. We all know it.
It's like the U S Ukraine and then Canada. Telemedia. I said that.
All right, guys. Well,
give a big round of applies for ed designer of the $10 million studio.
Go subscribe to his channel. Be memorable. Thanks for coming by now with data,
the way I want to show you the rest of the studio guys,
someone I've always been very inspired by is Charlie Kelly from always sunny in
Philadelphia. This is a man who knows what's going on in the mailroom.
Uh, can we talk about the mail please?
Malcolm and dying to talk about the mail for you all day. Okay. Pepe, Silvia,
this name keeps coming up over and over again. Every day.
Peppa is mail is getting sent back to me that they sold me up at Bay Sylvia.
I look at the milk was this whole process.
So obviously I had to do a bit of an homage to that.
This is our research corner, ladies and gentlemen, right here. Boom.
This is where we uncover. What's really going on in the world in the deep state,
whatever you want to call it. She knows I'm not a conspiracy guy,
but if something slides across my desk, it's interesting. If that makes sense,
this is where we're going to talk about it. Next.
I want to show you where all the calculations are done because guys,
the days of the gumshoe detective is over the era of internet.
Detectives is here. Most fraud is done online. And to catch that fraud,
you need the cutting edge computers, the cutting edge graphics cards.
CPU's sound cards. You need the cutting edge, everything.
Now I will tell you that this over here,
it also doubles as an incredible battle station to play among us to play
fall. Guys, no games that are graphic intensive, right?
We don't play little baby party games like call of duty.
We only play the most graphic intensive games that require 20 RTX,
20, 80 Nvidia graphics cards. That's all we do.
But this is mostly where we monitor the social accounts of all these gurus,
where we find out what the, the latest fraud is before anyone else does.
You guys know the FTC oftentimes out to lunch.
So hopefully we can catch a few things here.
This is where we're going to do that at next,
when the investigation winds down, when we need to relax,
I don't know if you guys know this, but I have a passion for playing piano.
So we had to of course, throw a grand piano in there. Something that, uh,
you know, it's fully playable.
You guys know that this is a real $10 million studio set,
and that would not be complete without a real.
This is really neat playing.
That another time, just when we're, we're just,
maybe people are filing in for a live stream, whatever we're doing,
this is where we can have that kind of rapport.
We're going to play some banger songs hits top 100 charts songs.
This is where there'll be played at. Everyone knows that the,
the real cutting edge music and pop is jazz piano. So
That's where we're going to do it. Guys. Everyone knows that's the new thing,
new wave. So that's where it's going to happen. Moving on one last thing,
if you're not convinced yet the coffee's Hill is going places.
The new season of coffee's Hill is going to be the best yet.
Let me give you guys some incentive. First of all,
this channel would be nothing without each and every one of you guys at home
watching, supporting subscribing sharing.
And I want to give back to you guys.
So I had this idea that at 1 million subscribers,
we're going to do something massive.
And this is the 1 million subscribers DOR.
Currently our big surprise taped up. You know,
it's going to be bigger than Mr. Beast.
It's going to be bigger than all these other big YouTubers.
You'd like to throw giant events. It's going to be bigger than that.
Bigger than Fortnite, bigger than I dunno. What's the new game. Cyberpunk 20,
77 guys. When we hit 1 million subscribers,
we're going to break it down, open this door. And the world of coffees,
Zillow will never be the same. So if any of this interests, you guys,
the detective stuff, the investigations, the new AR everything about it,
the jazz, if that's something that you're into,
please consider subscribing supporting the channel.
I'm so grateful that you guys got me here and I want to take it even farther.
I want to give you guys products. You're proud of.
I really believe that we can start competing production for production
with the best of, uh, with the Netflixes of the world. Okay?
Maybe not Netflix yet, but TV for sure.
We're going places that no one's gone before. And if you'd like to join up,
now's a great time to do it. We only have 200,000 subscribers.
We're going right to the moon boys.
So I hope you enjoyed this brief tour of the studio. This is only the beginning.
You guys should see this place when it goes to night. I mean,
when the investigation turns a little darker guys, it goes even further. But I,
I don't want to spoil too much, honestly.
I want you guys to experience it the way I did the first time.
I'm just really over the moon about how all of this turned out.
I can't even explain it. Like I'm so excited for what the future holds.
I don't remember the last time I've been this excited about the future of my
channel. And you know, I can honestly say this next season of coffee.
Zilla is going to be one to remember. Thank you guys for watching.
Thanks to all of you. Who've inspired me along the way.
Who've supported me along the way. I wouldn't be here without you guys.
We'll see you in the next investigation.
[Inaudible].